one's got many a top-ranking of
something about it something out into it
in and out my ministry as I will receive
you find it this is just a start of the
link it's good up to 32 a lovely can't
we just had lunch wake up by the wrong
way it's not a butt sexy would have been
nice this week what's out anywhere I was
a very very also happy this is totally
people to know but I'm 12 seen the guard
so tomorrow evening across all those
okay morning in for Julian nex-5 so
can't see the content
zerlina Monday morning's breakfast out
there so hopefully from be too
dominating and liked ones the licensing
committee this morning and just joining
us this before supplementing my life to
anarkali emergency evacuation
announcement should we do before I can
backtrack the building would you please
leave number by the dogs the fire escape
staircase these high point 10,000 cases
there's a racial slur anyone to announce
user stairs but they please their others
exit the room before there goes the fire
escape door without an identity given
your systems our assembly quite a bit
above the car park outside of the civic
sweet please do not delay evacuation to
collect any blames the used to not
return to building until giving
permission to do so by the council stuff
and apologies for absence from accounts
that they've merrick and also from
Council amazing this been substituted by
Councillor John Mason an apologist
encounter service is done by V Smith
substituted back answer that this is
Mason other any other colleges of you
know
another anyone be attending thank you
can we just go to them into our database
with a sister Gina coughing they were
previously circulated a rotation and
synthetic fix it and they're great
members read Norman great offensive
amazing game and also the minutes of our
licensing sub-committee that was held an
18th of july for the 2,000 reviews place
those are going as well for these in
Peggy can i receive any declarations of
interest please okay chromecast
withstand tomayto tomayto client review
the Gambian flaming performance and
policy jangle on skis take us through
their abilities yeah thank you and
constipation and one out three months to
all our results and authorities and
anybody else that we thought would be
interested in the gambling policy and
have any comments and we've got one back
from a licensing solicitor with regard
to the fixed odds betting term machines
that are in and betting shops
just giving a bit of background on this
I did send over House of Commons
briefing paper I don't know who had
chance to have a little look at that
that is the art to date information on
this this is basically a came campaign
for the campaign campaign for Farah
gambling and basically these machines is
it's a hundred pounds and for that's 100
pound steak they want to reduce it down
to two pounds they feel that people are
getting into debt because they are
paying 100 pounds ago on these machines
at a time and people that can't afford
it or getting in today and obviously
struggling the gambling commission and
the government have looked at this
campaign and let me just go back the
Pharaoh can fit the camp over very
gambling they what they want to do is
reduce the number of machines currently
there's four per shot or they can have
up to four per shot Devon we've got
those and they won reduce it down to one
they want to reduce the current maximum
stake from a hundred pound down to two
pounds they want to remove the table
content from the fixed odds betting
terminals because the pace of these
games is faster than a real casino and
reduce the spin frequency by increasing
the currency layer 20 seconds between
each wager in 60 seconds so that was the
campaign that they're all tongue and the
letter refers to this about bringing
down the stakes now the government and
have done quite a lot of work on this
and they've done a lot of consultation
on this with and the betting companies
with people that use the betting
machines and they have come what they're
looking at now is then put a measuring
at the Melbourne where if a person comes
into a better shot and they want to
bet over 50 pounds which will be one of
these machines they have to give their
identification okay so after photo ID
and so forth to say who they are this
reduces it because they don't always
want to be none to be on the machines
and then found that this is reduced this
a lot now from the studies that they've
done now the government have looked at
what happened to right at the very
beginning was new and run electric to
say about these terminals because they
are in a deprived area people will get
an in-depth gambling and they have done
a lot of consultation there's been a lot
of study on it and where we are
currently just read out the response the
government currently does not support
calls to set out in the submission for a
reduction in the state sighs on b2
gaming machines we are not convinced
that the local authorities of yet made
the most of the powers that are already
available to them and under either
planning or gambling law in terms of
gambling it is perhaps an uncomfortable
reality that every one of the betting
shops that collectively have given rise
to the concern at the heart of the
submission relies on a premises licence
granted by the local authority itself
while local authorities are bound by law
to aim to permit gambling insofar as
reasonable consistence with the
licensing objectives the licensing
process gives authorities considerable
scope to attach additional conditions to
licenses where there is necessary to
achieve the lysis in objectives so
review license ends once they've been
granted and power to impose licensing
conditions after review so basically
what they're saying is they don't agree
with bringing it down to two pounds and
they think that it will increase the
betting because the stake an hour is to
pay instead of 100 pounds and they are
looking at further measures we think
further legislation movie coming in on
these machines
studies are being done with the gambling
commission is work being done with the
government and there's also a lot of
gambling charities and things that are
working together so I think it support
the suggestions that the proposed to us
by a mr. new life is a little early I
think we will see some legislation come
in regarding these machines and some of
the things we can't be in a minute is
asked and for the wage are more than to
pappas think we can't do that that's
legislation it needs is through the
gambling commission we don't set how
much these machines steaks off that's
done all done by the gamification so if
we put this in our policy our premises
are straight away in breach of our
conditions because we've put that in our
policies so I think my advice to the
committee would be just to hold back
let's wait and see what comes in in
legislation it let's see what comes in
school to the end of the year we can
always update this post I policy to what
comes in and we also also talks about
our local area profile we have got one
on the website and it's not it does it
wrote it as part of the policy it's not
part of the documents so that will be
reviewed year they call when things
change so if you'll get premises are
closed if we get a new school come up
that can be added at any time we don't
have to bring it back to committee so
that is an ongoing update which is what
they laughs this is dope
and so my Bartleby won't see please
that's a promise thank you Jim yes I
must when I read this with a certain
amount of trepidation wondering where
would we be if we didn't do as this
solicitor suggesting so it's been very
useful to help obviously that there's no
obligation or else to do anything but I
did hear in the response was it too new
room yes but there were things we can do
provisions restrictions limitations that
we could put on individual applications
or renewal application is displaying
those to us what could we do and
application when they first come on we
can put conditions on like any other
licensed also if we find we've got a
problem betting shop we can bring that
to review and we can bring in front of
you guys and you can put conditions on
that as well so that is basically what
they're saying is that we have got
powers if necessarily that we find a
better shot is a particular problem we
can bring it to review and minute before
you and you can put conditions on that
to bring the betting shop in tonight but
to be fair we have got seven betting
shops in our district and they are all
betfred coral lag book and william here
we haven't got any you know individual
ones they're all from big companies
they're very much they all have their
own staff training so that they start
all going into that if they see somebody
betting a lot they will go and interact
and say to them you know we've been in
there a long time and you like you like
to come out and have a cuppa tea would
you like a break so that they come a way
to think about how much they're spending
they also with the cash machines by law
they're not allowed to be anywhere near
the machine so they have to come away
from the machine to go and get more
money and staff are trained to recognize
these signs I did in a whole day
training a casino and strap at the
biggest scene on Stratford and they are
very much aware of people getting out of
their depth they also they see somebody
very regular they will intervene there's
also a campaign as well that people that
gamble can actually self exclude this'll
so they can go to that betting shop and
say I'm trying to stop please don't let
me in and that can go rattled along for
once as well so you know they are so far
from over local ones so there is a lot
of campaigns going on to help people
that have got gambling problems I have a
following reasons and the follow-up same
thank you for joining me how exactly
you better just be having the district
or any of them in before we would call
deprived areas from time to time there
is a survey of the district and we know
where our most deprived areas are and
why are any of the betting shops in
those areas now we've got them in my
lane we've got them in motion and going
in half but they're not in rockford town
as such and so now I would say there any
other deprived areas and we certainly
have not had any problems I've not at
any reports my last three years to say
that without any problems or anybody to
the particular betting problem because
if they go to get help obviously the
organization they get hot from will
contact us and I'm not a very protective
children in the last three years thank
you chose I'm Joker I thank you very
much how's the Christine Rose did you
have question as well yes I do I listen
to thee for certain i quickly read this
appendix but I still must say that there
are some points here I don't know how
many members here listen to the news
this morning on the news there was a an
article that know they have established
that people with a on these fixed odds
betting terminals when they're in front
of them that it creates a brain activity
that they can neither control or stop
their bearing that in mind and I think
the other aspect that was covered I mean
it was only a snippet obviously we think
there's a forward
later tonight was that there is a lack
of support at people in those
difficulties and one percent effective
it is sometimes best to wait for
government to act if there's anything
that we can do as a counselor to try to
assist think without difficulty I accept
the offices comments that we probably
haven't identified any present it
doesn't mean they're not there and
there's two aspects that I'd like you to
consider on from this letter one is the
policy statement at number one I can't
see why we wouldn't be endorsing that
with birds also at number six the
misdemeanor has said that we should ask
them to report vandalisms to leave Oh
pts so that we can I change to imagine
out that what you're saying is correct
the report will be zero there will be no
reports however if that is in our policy
that we can be confident that it is zero
and not rely on the operators to inform
us voluntarily for certain amount of six
I would like to hear what your views are
about incorporating that and they can be
incorporated as a site these are big
companies we haven't got the smaller
companies like a lot of areas have so
they would have measures in place and
you know they are very responsible
companies I know they're betting
companies but they are various notes or
companies but yet that certainly can go
in if that's you know what you decide
that that's fine yeah it's happened a
good indication you come back
mr. Chairman I think that we have a
voice we may have a situation that is
now is under control and satisfactory
what our policy should do is cover all
eventualities that we can foresee and I
would like this committee to consider
incorporating item 6 in the home safe
thank you thank you does he know no
house have a view on that please do we
have we had any complaints from people
my initial thoughts on reducing the
state to penalties that would bring a
lot more people into using it concerns
regarding that and what's the difference
between that an online betting policy I
guess the difficulties yeah make a lick
online betting those would be
responsible for the licensees good being
what you disagree with lilo would that
make much difference to the online if
you don't get it in the betting shops
your online exactly to the way to turn
please the online betting began by
Commission are doing the heavy mount
work on online betting because a lot of
this comes from abroad it doesn't come
from this country as to say they are
looking at this as a measure they're
looking at you know the stake they're
looking at the fixed terminal state they
are doing a lot of work honestly doing a
lot of consultation on this and as well
as be online so there is a lot of work
going on as I say the points 1 and 6
that you've mentioned on a 60s yeah
that's fine and it's just I would be a
little bit and hold back a little bit on
this two pounds because that's going to
come from government and we can't the
only gotten that not we can't do that so
thank you
does anyone else have any comments about
the report
if we were three P's and osborn 6j with
that affect close its importance in any
way yeah you get the studio no that'd be
fun I'll remember meeting me later okay
thank you
in that case can I recommend country in
the radio they do not support us
including
Oh
Dinah cueva members
the
issue seen a license agreement district
thank you very much I've been buddies in
gender thank you very much for attending